We have a code
red situation.
We're going to make
some changes.
We're
installing sensors
underneath everyone's desks.
We want you to be
the face of this initiative.
This is a chance for you
to step into a management role.
I knew this day
would come.
You look like
so super good today. I'm sorry.
We want to create
a culture of shame.
Do you two
have desk sensors?
No. We're your
superiors and above the law.
But, we're also you're friends
and the same as all of you.
Ow. Oh.
Hampton DeVille.
Welcome to hell.
Hi, I work
at Hampton DeVille.
Where do you work?
Wee.
I'm so happy.
Oh happy and lucky me.
This is our floor.
It's very sad.
I go 35 times a day.
Jesus.
You have flaws.
-What are they?
-I got married.
Lauren.
It's Laura.
What?
My name is Laura.
Oh man.
I am
officially off the market.
Let's definitely stay
in touch.
I'm desperate
to stay in touch.
That's gross.
... Aw ...f-
Let me
give you my card.
-Here's my card.
Card. Card. Card. Card.
Card. Card. Card.
Card. Card.